hallo das ist meine neue frage okay hier
sind erstmal meine fragen es ist eine längere
frage du hast jetzt schon eine zeit lang musik gefunden
also wie war es deinen
ersten vertrag zu unterschreiben und natürlich was hat
sich seitdem in deinem leben verändert und
natürlich seit ihrem erfolg  Als ich
meinen ersten Vertrag unterschrieb, ging es um dich,
Tina, danke, und es war ein unglaubliches Gefühl
und ich war sehr aufgeregt, und offensichtlich lief
alles sehr gut, und deshalb
war es ein wirklich guter Tag,
und ich erinnere mich jetzt daran, dass ich es bin.
Ich werde mich immer daran erinnern. Ich weiß, dass es so viele glückliche
Erinnerungen gab, die danach kamen,
denjenigen zu touren, der diese
erstaunlichen Konzerte übrigens nicht gespielt hat. Erfolg, hast
du mehr Erfolg mit Männern oder nicht.
Hier bin ich, ich weiß nicht  Um
ehrlich zu sein, interessiere ich mich nicht wirklich für Männer, also
bemerke ich dich nicht wirklich